[Music]
all right thanks everyone for coming to
io103 monitoring and forecasting your
gcp costs
um i'm stephen elliott i'm a product
manager on google cloud billing and my
colleague here
phil coletti um that's phil with 2ls and
he's also
a product manager on google cloud
billing and we're really excited here to
talk to you about
cost management in the cloud and on
google cloud platform in particular
but just to get started i just want to
get a quick show of hands and get a
sense of who's in the audience
how many of you uh use any cloud
provider today
okay vast majority how many of you are
on google cloud platform today
and then maybe the flip side how many of
you're evaluating but not on google
cloud yet
great and then rough sense
how many of you feel like you are really
good at managing and monitoring google
cloud
cloud provider costs
the third and how many of you feel like
you you
need to learn something or need some
help or tools to help with it okay
great got it so um
before we dive into kind of the meat of
how cost reporting works on google cloud
i want to do a little introductory trip
into cost management the cloud with a
company you've probably heard of before
waze if you live in the bay area you
might even use ways to get here
waze was founded in 2008 it was called
free map israel i believe and it was
acquired by google in 2013 so now it's a
google company
and obviously they run part of their
infrastructure on google cloud platform
or else i wouldn't be including them in
this talk
one of the things they do which you are
familiar with is their traffic
application
they help you navigate and get to where
you need to go they find the best route
for you based on
help from other drivers and this is
actually a map of
where phil and i work in seattle and
it's showing you three routes from
downtown seattle
to fremont now two of the routes i don't
recommend but the fastest route does
seem like the route i would take to get
from
the hilton downtown to fremont and right
where that google cloud logo is
is google in fremont
and you can kind of see what waze is
doing here it has uh
traffic uh notifications based on
drivers so
you this is all coming in from driver's
apps there's heavy traffic on the 520
bridge there's basically heavy traffic
everywhere in seattle this morning at
9am
that's pretty standard there's also
other events like uh
these pink uh barricades are showing
where drivers are reporting
you know roads are shut down there's a
policeman apparently in inter bay
and there's construction workers
downtown so the important thing about
this is
waze is doing this as you know all over
the world for millions of users
they're in 185 countries and they have
500 000 maps contributors
and we all know that route navigation
and route finding is already a
computationally hard problem
and waze is doing a lot more than just
that so it's doing this for millions of
users
around the world in real time it's also
doing anomaly detection
it's reporting what it thinks might be
safety incidents to local authorities
it's doing sentiment analysis on users
to make sure that their
experience on the waze app is good it's
taking all those map contributions in
and it's doing this in every major city
and you can kind of see what i love
about this video and you can see
a series of these on youtube is how waze
is living and breathing
as it's serving its customers and
in particular all of its services on
this
on this chart and on this slide and
elsewhere are
spinning up and spinning down with waze
customer demand so
in the morning when waze customers are
driving waze is spinning up more compute
resources there's more
bigquery activity there's more big data
activity
storage and database management
networking activity
and actually in a chart later on this uh
presentation you'll see what's happening
and this is a really cool aspect of all
of these services and of being in the
cloud is that they're all available on
demand
and they literally uh kind of breathe in
and out with the demand on the
infrastructure
so that's something i just want to talk
about and frame this talk a little bit
before we dive into the cost reporting
tools
is one of the things you probably hear a
lot about moving
onto the cloud from a legacy provider or
operating on various cloud providers is
the ability to trade
capital expenditures for operational
expenditures um so here's just an
illustrative over simplification
cost on the y-axis and time on the
x-axis
and this might be you know hypothetical
application and you're forecasting the
demand that application will have on
your infrastructure
and in the traditional world
you'd have to make sure you plan ahead
and buy that infrastructure and procure
the hardware in advance and this this
timeline could be anywhere between days
two weeks and usually it's more like
months
three months to six months to get the
data center in place to get the capacity
you need to run a new application
to get the past the capacity you need to
launch in a new region to launch your
business internationally to serve
international customers
now in the worst case scenario you get
it wrong um
and your demand exceeds what you plan
for and
this either results in unserved demand
or unhappy customers
and so that's usually why you try to
over provision to make sure you don't
hit that
and then it's a balancing act because
you don't want to over to overprovision
too much because in the best case
scenario
you have unused capacity
so the obvious immediate benefit of
moving from capital expenditures to
operational expenditures is this unused
capacity
becomes unused capacity savings so
that's capacity you didn't have to use
you didn't have to spin up
and all of those services on the google
cloud platform slide that waze uses
don't incur costs for waze
but there's another value that i want
you to think hard about and sometimes
this gets lost in some discussions about
cost monitoring and cost forecasting um
is
the ability to meet surprise demand so
this could be very simply
you know a social media app in the early
2000s scales really fast and shuts down
because it wasn't able to meet demand in
its data centers
or you're delivering traffic more slowly
and it's just a bad customer experience
but another way to think about it is
also what are the projects that your
company's not doing because
your employees are kind of stymied they
they realize it's going to take three
months to get a project off the ground
to even run a pilot
and so they don't bother asking we all
work in knowledge economies
we have very important employees who
might be the most valuable thing
that we have in our companies and
whenever we slow down the work
that they want to do that has really
drastic implications for our business so
um one of my colleagues matt leonard
gave a talk with lucas carlson at the
broad institute and the broad was
the first to uh sequence the humanum
genome and i if i recall correctly has
sequenced a hundred thousand
since they started and you can imagine
if there's any delay
um if there's a significant delay when
researchers can actually get results
that impacts not just the broad but
actually um
i mean this is kind of over emphasizing
but mankind they're like the time to
science
uh is very long um
so some key questions i just want to put
in your head and you can ask yourself
these questions as you go through
the demo with phil are these three so
how much
does my app cost what are my cost trends
and what are the drivers of those trends
and what i like about these questions is
they're kind of fractal
they apply to any level of the
organization and you'll find that
your cio or cto is asking the question
and you also find that the developer
actually creating the application
operating the application needs to be
able to answer these questions
as well in very fine detail
so we can give you
at a glance answers to all three of
these questions even for one of our
biggest customers so i want to
illustrate this with waze carpool
um waze carpool launched i think in
california last year and then in
washington
earlier this year and it allows drivers
to pair up with riders
and for a nominal compensation to be
exchanged between the two so that
you can carpool effectively to work
spend time with people you enjoy so you
can set preferences on who you drive
with
and get there faster in the hov lane and
reduce commute costs
so this is what waze cost look like in
our reports dashboard
earlier this year so they had this is
kind of a nice view because it also
shows you a general pattern with what
cloud costs usually look like which is
compute costs tend to be the large cost
and that makes sense
um and there's cyclicality and
periodicity in your in your costs
it may correspond to daily cyclicality
so waze has that
with date morning and evening commutes
or like seasonal cyclicality
retail retail periods other things like
that
but in general there's a longer term
secular trend of those costs
that also keeps the cloud administrator
confident that their
environment isn't running out of control
that they don't have runaway costs
um but you know just at a glance you can
see something happened
earlier last year where there was a big
spike i i presume waze investigated that
because that doesn't look like it was
normal
a couple maybe a few months ago there
was a smaller spike may or may not have
been normal and that's worth
investigating so just at a glance
waze can log into the cloud console on
gcp and see what's going on with their
service
and again a service that serves over 100
million users
where they've driven you know 22 and a
half billion kilometers
is all kind of represented by the
infrastructure on this chart
so then they launched waze carpool um
and this was the trend after they
launched ways carpool
and so immediately you've we've answered
um at a high level the three questions
what are what's my spending level
so you have the spending level at any
moment of time what's the trend and you
have this
short-term trend but also the long-term
trend which is more interesting one of
the questions i would want to ask myself
launching a new services
is the cost growth good is it growing
sublinearly with customer demand
is it in control or is something
happening where our costs are
spiraling out of control compared to the
demand we expected um
and this shows kind of a nice story of
what the secular growth was before they
launched this major new feature and what
it looked like
after they launched the feature and you
can also see that nothing big
changed um about their makeup at least
at a glance here
compute costs still seem to be the same
fraction bigquery analysis cost cloud
storage
and so forth so just this visual
understanding of cloud cost is very
powerful because
the visual explanation is just a really
good way to communicate the structure of
costs
so i just want to do one footnote before
we head into how to track
cloud costs because there's really two
ways to go about it
one way is tops down you could use the
resource hierarchy and put resources in
a project everything on google cloud
platform is assigned to a project and
you
can set up an organization folders under
that organization
projects under each folder and then
resources within a project
and users operate within projects they
have permissions to create resources
within projects and so if you've created
a nice project hierarchy and you've
thought well about it
you know you could have a project that's
corresponds to an application and then
all the costs in that project
are application costs or you could have
a project that captures
all of an environment like the dev
environment so all the costs in that
project would be the dev environment
costs
and so forth the other way to track
costs is bottoms up through labels
and labels apply to resources so you can
ask your developers or set up tools that
automatically attach labels to resources
that are created
and then you can get basically made kind
of matrix allocation of costs you might
say okay within
project a i know my costs are x
in total but i also know that you know
the environment
prod in project a cost in some fraction
of x environment dev
cost some other fraction and so on and
that's how you can use labels
um you can also attach other important
metadata like who's the owner of the
resource
um what's the cost center things like
that so these are two things to think
about
as you're about how you want to monitor
and manage costs in google cloud
platform
so we're going to focus a lot of today
on billing reports
but i just want to make you aware of a
couple of other
major features that might be useful to
you in monitoring and managing
cloud costs one is billing export the
other is budgets and alerts
and the last one which we'll do kind of
an in-depth demo on is billing reports
so billing export is really where you
would kind of just dive in
um write detailed queries and kind of
answer customized questions about your
cloud costs
all of the labels go into billing export
you see what service was used
what sku was used details about
the project and and the sku and over
time we'll be adding more and more
information to bigquery export
and what's cool about this is you can
connect to other tools like data studio
there's another talk we gave explaining
how to do that
and so this really allows you to answer
fine-grained questions about
cloud costs the next feature we have
budgets and alerts is really worth
taking a look at
you can set budgets at the billing
account or project level
and then set thresholds for when you
want to be notified
about that budget and the notification
can happen via email
or programmatically via pub subs so
email's great for cloud administrators
who just want to be aware of things and
may not be operating a large scale
operation but pub sub and programmatic
notifications are especially cool if
you're running a really large
application or if you're technically
savvy
and can set up really simple responses
to those notifications like oh
if project a exceeds 90 please start
throttling project a
and that unleashes a very cool solutions
for your organization
and matt and lucas carlson from the
broad gave a very cool talk about that
earlier it'll be on youtube
so now i'll turn it over to phil and
he'll walk you through billing reports
so now we're going to dive into the
billing reports tool in a little bit
more detail
and we'll do that through the lens of
our hypothetical enterprise acme company
uh and they want to answer the same
questions as most other i.t
organizations
what are my costs what are my cost
trends and what are my cost drivers
but before we actually look at the tool
in too much great detail
a quick show of hands who here has used
google cloud billing reports in the
cloud console
looks like maybe 30 okay so
for some of you uh you may have already
seen this tool and used it
for others of you it may be familiar
given some other bi tools that you've
used
and for many of us this may be first
time seeing it so we'll learn something
can we cut back over to the demo please
fantastic um first let's just take a
quick look at the tool
um i'll give a quick walk through and
then we can look at answering those
questions
so for starters we can get to this by
going to
the billing tab and the reports section
right at the top here of the page we
have a summary bar
which includes high level information
about what our costs are
for our app below that we have a
chart that lets us analyze trends and
see how
our usage breaks down and then at the
bottom we have a table
that summarizes and rolls up the
information from that chart
lastly on the right section of the page
we have grouping and filter controls
that let us slice and dice our data
and filter down to the scope of spend
that's relevant for us to look at
okay so to answer those questions first
what are our costs
the summary bar gives us a really nice
concise answer to that
so far in the first 26 days of july
for our demo here we've spent 1400
for the entire month of july looking at
the right half of the summary bar we can
see that we're forecasted to spend about
eighteen
hundred dollars so we can see easily
that the summary bar it gives us a
really nice quick answer
that we can answer that question in
maybe five seconds
next what are our cost trends
in the first 26 days of july it looks
like our costs are down about three and
a half percent over the preceding 26 day
period
but for the entire month of july it
looks like we're forecasted to spend
about eight and a half percent more than
we did in the month of june this is
because we're growing
also because july has one more day than
june so we would expect costs to go up a
little bit anyways
but to look at these trends in more
detail i'm going to look down at the
chart
a few things here to note one um we have
a stacked line chart
so the total height of the stacked line
is
what we're spending um on a daily level
but each one of these segments
represents a meaningful portion of our
spend
um here we're grouping by project so
each one of these colored segments
represents the spend for a single
project
at acme company we organize our
applications into projects so each one
of these colored segments
is how much we're spending on one
application for one day
lastly we have a dotted gray line here
that represents
our cost trend and this is how we get to
this forecasted cost number for the
month
um the forecasted cost is the sum
of our actual spend to date and our
forecasted spend for
the remainder of the month
um but to look at i want to explain a
little bit how we get to this cost
trend number it's a feature we've rolled
out recently
and it's pretty powerful so i'm going to
select the custom date range here
just so that we can get a little more
context
i'll look at the period from may 1st
to august 25th okay
so for the purposes of the demo we
created this account sometime in mid-may
and the account grew along with our
hypothetical demand
and the cost trend picks up on that
long-term secular stable trend
and it projects it out up to about a
month into the future
so the way this works is we take the
entire
history for the billing account all the
spend that you've had to date and we
look for
the most recent stable long-term trend
so
maybe if you launched the new
application like waze carpool it would
start at that point or if you went
through a major cost optimization effort
it might start after that
it also does a good job of ignoring
spikes like we see here in the middle of
june
so it really just picks up on whatever
your organic growth trend is
and will forecast that forward into the
future
great so now we kind of have a quick
answer of our first two questions
what are my costs and what are my cost
trends
but we've answered this only for the
entire billing account
what if we want to know a little bit
more about a single application in this
case
let's say phil's amazing application not
to toot my own horn too much
um we can answer the same questions just
by filtering down to that one project
we can see that so far we've spent 450
on the application this month
we're expected to spend about 600 in the
month of july
and that represents about a 36 percent
growth
over the month of june
okay
so lastly the one the one question we
haven't really dove into too much yet is
what are my cost
drivers um so to do that i want to
go back to those spikes that we saw in
june i've selected the previous month
here so we can look at those in a bit
more detail
so here we see a spike around june 8th
and we see another spike around june
11th
and i want to know at a high level what
changed to cause those spikes
the chart's a really powerful tool for
doing this and we can quickly see just
by hovering over this section that
this orange slice which was our good
enough project that really changed a lot
it grew at that time
and it also grew for the june 11th spike
on that june 11 spike we also see that
we had some growth in this
blue segment which was phil's amazing
application but i can get a little more
detail i want to understand
what changed in those applications to
cause those spikes
and let's look at good enough project
first so i'll filter down to just that
project
and then i want to ask the question
which products or services
changed to cause the cost to increase so
i'll group
by product instead of by project
and now i can see that bigquery all of a
sudden went from nothing to 28
overnight and that may have been
unexpected it may have been something we
planned for
we can get even a little more detail and
see what happened in bigquery
by filtering down to just that product
and grouping by skew to see if there are
any trends in the skus that we were
using
so not surprisingly it's analysis not
storage that
fluctuated really highly up and then
came back down um
and at this point this is about as much
detail as we can get from this report
but we might want to go talk to say our
data science team
and learn what kinds of queers they were
running and if you know they were
pulling a data set to build a new
predictive model that we get a lot of
value out of that may be totally fine
if however we want to trade off some of
the flexibility
for a little more predictable and
controllable costs we might want to look
into something like
flat rate bigquery pricing
okay
so now i want to go through a similar
process and try to understand what
happened in phil's amazing application
in the middle of june so again
i'm going to filter down to just phil's
amazing application
and we can see just by hovering over the
chart we were spending about eight
dollars a day
and then it jumped up to about 35 a day
sometime in mid-june
and that's something i'd want to know
say what products what services changed
so again i'll filter down to just
compute engine
sorry jumped ahead
i would group by product and i would see
what products changed
in this case we can see in phil's
amazing application
we run two products or services both app
engine and compute engine
and compute engine is where the change
occurred and again we can get a little
more detail by looking at what our
changes were in our skus
so here i'll just filter down to compute
engine and group by skew
and there's a couple changes that we can
see here during that spike
normally just by hovering over i can see
we run n1 standard ones which is our
smallest standard machine type of the n1
family
but then right here in the middle of the
month
we see a couple other flavors of sku and
one standard eights and then one
standard 16s which are bigger and more
expensive than what we normally run
and again this is about as much detail
as you can get from a high level report
but you might want to dive into more
detailed data
in like your stack driver logs or in our
bigquery billing export
or we might go talk to the project owner
or the engineer and say hey
is there a reason why we're running
these bigger machines
and why we didn't spend them down for a
few days afterwards
additionally when we see something like
that if it's unexpected
we may want to set up a passive
monitoring solution like
budgets and alerts so that we're
notified if our spend trends quicker
than we expect at this point we can cut
back over to the slides
so now we've gone through a demo of
billing reports we've seen how we can
use this tool to really quickly get a
high level answer to our three key cost
management questions
and we've also seen how we can get to a
certain level of depth
at which point we need to go to either a
more detailed
data source like our billing export or
like
stackdriver logs to get even more rich
detail about say machine utilization
or we can go talk to the relevant teams
to figure out what happened when we see
spikes like we did in the middle of june
so that concludes our demo um before we
wrap up
i just want to highlight a couple of
other sessions related to cost
management and billing
on tuesday we had a talk by james byers
on how to
organize and structure your resources
which also relates to the slide that
steven went through earlier about labels
versus
projects and folders yes
we also had a pretty cool talk yesterday
with dale and dale from vendasta where
they did some interesting live demos
about how to use
bigquery export and data studio to slice
and dice your data
and lastly matt and lucas carlson
talked a bit about how we can control
our cloud costs with financial
governance tools
we also have a showcase downstairs on
the bottom floor of moscone west
please stop by and say hi we'll be there
probably after this presentation
[Music]
you